you write quote will start our Pitchfork
tour in this chapter by taking a brief
trip through the history of the
Republican party then in the following
chapters we'll take a Tim's career
tanking Deep dive into America's social
justice movement as you started to talk
about okay so let's go uh what's the
history of the Republican Party
I'm looking at this through my vertical
ladder I'm saying what is this this
familiar story of the Republicans from
the 60s to today what does it look like
through the vertical lens right does it
look different and and and is there is
there an interesting story here that's
been kind of hidden because we're always
looking at the horizontal now the
horizontal story you'll hear people talk
about it and it's they'll say something
like the Republicans have moved farther
and farther to the right and
um and to me that that's not really true
like it was Trump more right-wing than
Reagan I don't think so I think he's
left actual policy yeah yeah so it's so
we're using this again it's just like
you're calling yourself Centrist but
it's not exactly what you mean even
though it also is yeah
so I again this I was like okay look
this vertical lens helps with other
things let's apply it to the Republicans
and here here's what I saw is
I looked at the 60s
and
I saw an interesting story which I don't
think that you know not everyone's
familiar with like what happened in the
early 60s but in 1960 the Republican
party was very it was a plurality you
had progressives like genuine
Rockefeller you know pretty Progressive
people
um all the way to you know then you had
them you know moderates like Eisenhower
and Dewey and then you go all the way to
the you know farther right you had gold
water and you know what you might call I
I call them the fundamentalists um
and so
it's this interesting plurality right
something we don't have today and what
happened was the the Goldwater
contingent which was the Underdog they
were small right that Eisenhower was the
president
uh or had just been the president and
was it seemed like the moderates were
you know it was that's the he said you
have to be close to the center of the
chess board that's right that's that's
how you maintain power these people were
very far from the center of the
chessboard but they ended up basically
have like a hostile takeover they
conquered their own party and they did
it by breaking all of the kind of
Unwritten rules and Norms so they did
things like they first started with like
the college Republicans which was like
this feeder group that turned in you
know a lot of the politicians started
there and they they went to the election
and they wouldn't let the the the
current president the incumbent speak
and they were throwing chairs and they
were fist fights and eventually people
gave up and they just sat there and they
sat in the chair talking for you know
their their got their candidate until
everyone eventually left and then they
declared Victory so they basically they
they they they they came in there there
was a there was a certain set of rules
agreed upon rules and they came in
playing the power games saying well
actually
if we do this you won't have the power
you know we have the power to to take it
if we just break all the rules right and
so they did and they won and that became
this hugely influential thing which then
they then they conquered California
through again these these people were
taken aback these you know these these
proper Republican candidates were
appalled by the kind of like you know
the insults they were being hurled with
them and the intimidation in the
building and eventually they ended up in
the National Convention which was called
like the right wing Woodstock it was
like you know the Republican National
Convention in 64 was just they again it
was jeering and they wouldn't let their
moderates so their their progressives
even speak and there was racism you know
you know Jackie Robinson was there and
he was a proud Republican and he said
that like he feels like he was a Jew in
Hitler's Germany with the way the blacks
were being treated there and it was
nasty and but what did they do they they
had they had fiery you know plurality
enough to win um and they won they ended
up getting crushed in the general
election and they kind of faded away but
to me I was like what that was an
interesting story I see it as
um I have this character in the book
called The Golem which is a big kind of
a big dumb powerful monster that's the
you know the emergent property of like a
political Echo chamber it's like this
big giant it's stupid but it's powerful
and scary
um and to me I was like a Golem rose up
conquered the party for a second knocked
it on its ass and then
and then faded away and to me when I
looked at the Trump Revolution and a lot
and not just Trump the last 20 years I
see that same lower right that lower
right monster kind of
um
making another charge for it but this
time succeeding and really taking over
the party for a long period of time I
see the same story which is the power
games are being played
um in a situation when it had always
been the government relies on all these
Unwritten rules and Norms to function
but for example you have in 2016 Merrick
Garland gets a gets nominated by Obama
and they're Unwritten Norm says that
when the president nominates a Justice
then you pass them through unless
there's some egregious thing that's what
has happened but they said actually this
is the last year of his presidency and
the people should choose I don't think
we should set a new precedent where you
the president can't nominate people uh
nominate a Supreme Court Justice in the
last year so they they pass it through
and it ends up being Gorsuch
um and so they they lose that seat now
three years later it's Trump's last year
and it's another election year
and Ginsburg dies and what did they say
they say oh let's keep our precedent
they said no oh actually we changed our
mind we're going to nominate Amy Barrett
so to me that is classic power games
right that there there's there's no
actual rule in what you're doing is they
had they did technically have the power
to block the nomination then and then
they technically had the power to put
someone and they and they're pretending
there's some principle to it but they're
just extra they're going for the a
short-term Edge at the expense of what
is like the workings of the system in
the long run and then what do the
Democrats have to do in that situation
because both parties have been doing
this is they either can lose now all the
time or they start playing the power
games too and now you have a prisoner's
dilemma where it's like both are end up
doing this thing because and then
everyone ends up worse off the debt
ceiling All these power plays that are
being made where these these holding the
country hostage this is power games and
to me that's what Goldwater was doing in
the 60s but it was a healthier time in a
way because there was this plurality
within the parties reduced some of the
national tribalism and that there wasn't
as much of an appeal to that but today
it's just like do whatever you have to
do to beat the enemies and so I'm seeing
a rise in power games and I talk about
the Republicans because they did a lot
of these things first they have been a
little bit more Regis but both parties
have been doing it over the last 20 30
years can you place uh blame or maybe
there's a different term for it
at uh the subsystems of this so is it
the media is it the politicians like in
the senate in Congress is it Trump so
the leadership is it
um or maybe it's us
human beings uh maybe social media
versus mainstream media is there a sense
of where what is the cause of what is
the symptom it's very complex so Ezra
clients a great book why we're polarized
where he talks about a lot of this and
there's there's some of these are you
know it's really no one's fault first of
all it's the environment has changed in
a bunch of ways you just mentioned and
what happens when you take human nature
which is a constant and you put it into
an environment
Behavior comes out the environment's the
independent variable when that changes
the dependent variable the behavior
changes with it right and so the
environment has changed in a lot of ways
so one major one is
it used to for a long time actually the
the the first there was the Republicans
and then the Democrats just had a
Stranglehold on Senate on Congress there
was no it was not even competitive the
Democrats for 40 years had the majority
and so therefore it actually isn't a
decent environment to compromise it
because now we can both you know what
you want is Congress people thinking
about their home district and and you
know voting yes on a national policy
because we're going to get a good deal
on it back at home that's actually
healthy as opposed to voting in lockstep
together because this is what the red
party is doing regardless of what's good
for my home District you know an example
is Obamacare you know there were certain
Republican districts that would have
actually officially been benefited by
Obamacare but every Republican voted
against it so and part of the reason is
because it's no longer this obvious
majority every few years it switches
it's a 50 50 thing and that's you know
partially because it's become so we've
been so subsumed with this one National
divide of left versus right that
um that that that cut people are not
people or whoever you know they're
voting for the same party for president
uh all the way down the ticket now and
so you have this just kind of 50 50
color war and that's awful for
compromise so there's like 10 of these
things you know that have redistricting
but also it is social media it is you
know I call it hyper charged tribalism
we've you know in the 60s you had kind
of distributed tribalism you had some
people that are worked up about the USSR
right they're National that's what they
care about U.S versus foreign some
people that were saying left versus
right like they today and then other
people that were saying that they were
fighting within the party but today you
don't have that it's it's the the you
have ideological realignment so you kind
of got rid of a lot of the in-party
fighting and then there's hasn't been
that big of a foreign threat not nothing
like the USSR for a long time so you
kind of lost that and what's left is
Justice left versus right thing and so
that's kind of this hypercharged
Whirlpool that subsumes everything and
um and so yeah yeah it's I mean you
people point to Newt Gingrich you know
people like there's certain characters
that enacted policies that stoked this
kind of thing but I I think this is a
much bigger kind of environmental shift
well that's going back to our questions
about the role of individuals in human
history so the the interesting one of
the many interesting questions is about
Trump is he a symptom or a Cause
because it seems to be from the public
narrative such a significant
Catalyst for some of the things we're
seeing this goes back to what we were
talking about earlier right like is it
is it the person or is the times I think
he's a perfect example of it's a both
situation I don't think that I don't
think if you pluck Trump out of the
situation I don't think Trump was
inevitable but I think we were very
vulnerable to a demagogue
and if you hadn't been Trump would have
had no chance and so what and why were
we vulnerable to a demagogue is because
you have these I mean I think it's
specifically on the right
if you actually look at the stats it's
pretty bad like the people who because
because it's not just who voted for
Trump a lot of people just vote for the
red right what's interesting is who
voted for Obama Against Romney and then
voted for Trump
who you know these are not racists right
these are not hardcore Republicans they
voted for Obama
and where did the switch come from
places that had economic despair where
Bridges were not working well that's a
signifier you know we're we're paint
chipping in the schools you know these
little things like this so I think that
you know you had this
a lot of these kind of rural towns you
have true Despair and then you also have
a and the number one indicator of voting
for Trump was distrust in media and the
media has become much less trustworthy
you know and so you you have the the all
these ingredients that actually make us
very vulnerable to a demagogue and a
demagogue is someone who takes advantage
right there's someone who comes in and
says I can pull all the right strings
and Pull and and and push all the right
emotional buttons right now and get
myself Power by taking advantage of the
circumstances and that is what Trump
totally did
it makes me wonder how easy it is for
somebody who's a charismatic leader to
uh capitalize on
cultural resentment when when there's
economic hardship to channel that so
John height wrote a great article about
like the true we basically we like truth
is in an all-time low right now like
it's the media is not penalized for
lying yeah right MSNBC Fox News these
are not penalized for being inaccurate
or penalized if they stray from the
Orthodoxy
on social media it's not the truest
tweets that go viral right and so Trump
understood that better than anyone right
he he took advantage of it he he was
living in the current world when
everyone else was stuck in the past and
he saw that and he just lied he
everything he said
you know it doesn't the truth was not
relevant at all right it's just it's
just truly it's not relevant to him when
what he's talking about he doesn't care
and and he knew that neither do is a
subset of the country I was thinking
about this just reading articles by
journalists
especially when you're not a a famous
journalist in yourself but you're more
like in your times journalists so the
big famous thing is the institution
you're part of that like you can just
lie yeah because you're not going to get
punished for it you're going to be
rewarded for of the popularity of an
article so if you write 10 articles
it's there's a huge incentive to just
make stuff up you got to get clicks to
get clicks that's the first and foremost
and like culturally
people will attack that article that
says it's not like one half the country
will attack that article saying is
dishonest but they'll kind of forget the
you will not have a reputational hit
right there won't be a memory like this
person made up a lot of stuff in the
past no they'll take one article at a
time and they'll attach the reputation
hits will be to New York Times the
institution yeah and so for the
individual journalists there's a huge
incentive to make stuff up totally it's
it's it it's and it's scary because
it's almost you can't survive if you're
just an old school honest journalist who
really works hard and tries to get it
right and does it with Nuance like well
you can be is you can be a big time sub
stacker or big time podcaster A lot of
people do have a reputation for accuracy
and rigor and they have huge audiences
but
um if you're working in a big company
right now
um it's I mean especially I mean I like
I I I think that many of the big media
brands are very much controlled by the
left and but I will say that the ones
that are controlled by the right are
even more egregious not just in terms of
accuracy but also in terms of you know
the New York Times for all of its
criticisms
they have a handful of uh they they
every they here and there they put out a
pretty
you know a an article that Strays from
the they know Barry Weiss wrote there
for a long time and then you've got
um they wrote an article criticizing
free speech on campus stuff you know
recently um and they have you know they
have a couple very you know left uh
Progressive friendly conservatives but
they have conservatives that are
operating the op-eds Fox News you know
you're not seeing thoughtful uh
Breitbart you're not seeing thoughtful
progressives writing there right there's
some degree to which the New York Times
I think still incentivizing the values
the vertical
the high effort so the you're allowed to
have a conservative opinion if you do a
really damn good job yeah like if it's a
very thorough in-depth art kind of and
if you kind of Pander to the progressive
senses in all the right ways you know I
always joke that you know Ted you always
have a couple you know token
conservatives but they get on stage and
they're basically like so totally you're
all you know where the the progressive
systems are that's right about all of
this but maybe maybe you know
libertarianism isn't all about you know
it's just so there is an element but you
know what it's it's something it's
better than than being a total tribal I
think you can you can see the New York
Times tug of war the internal tug of war
you can see it because then they also
have these awful instances you know or
like you know the firing of James
Bennett which is this whole other story
but like they have
you yeah you can see it going both ways
but in the 60s what did you have you had
ABC NBC CBS you know the 70s you know
you had these three news channels and
they weren't always right and they
definitely sometimes spun a narrative
together maybe about the Vietnam or
whatever but
they if one of them was just lying
they'd be embarrassed for it they would
be penalized they'd be dinged and they'd
be known as this is the trash one and
that would be terrible for their ratings
because they weren't just catering to
half the country they're allocating to
the whole country so both on the axis of
accuracy and on the axis of neutrality
they had to
you know try to stay somewhere in the
the reasonable range and that's just
gone one of the things I'm really
curious about is I think your book is
incredible
I'm very curious to see how it's written
about by the Press
because I could see click I could myself
write with the help of charge GPT of
course clickbait articles in either
direction yeah
it's easy to imagine your whole book is
beautifully written for click bait
articles yeah if any journalists out
there need help I can I can help you
yeah okay I can write out the most
atrocious criticisms yeah uh I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm ready I'm braced